das arzt kann ich nie sagen es kann
nichts passieren man kann nach einer
aspirin allergischen schock wegen mit
paracetamol und ibuprofen kann man sich
umbringen das ist alles möglich aber
diese impfung die wir jetzt in der hand
haben ist ein genialer streich der
wissenschaft an das kann man das gar
nicht sagen
wir haben nicht als ärzte damit
gerechnet dass wir so schnell den
impfstoff bekommen
es war einfach eine geniale idee das ist
jetzt umgesetzt worden
wir haben den impfstoff viel früher
bekommen als wir gedacht haben und
sollten wir optimistisch das ansehen und
nicht so viel negatives berichten nicht
so viel berichten dass das der und jene
die jetzt vielleicht nicht will ich
denke der ein oder andere der jetzt
nicht geimpft wird wird sich das auch
überlegen
ich selber habe mich impfen lassen
gestern und außer ein bisschen schmerzen
im einstichstelle ist nichts habe ich
merke ich nichts ich lebe noch und auch
alle patienten die ich gestern geimpft
habe sind erfreuen sich bester
gesundheit
wir hatten auch allergiker dabei also
ist bei niemand irgendwas aufgetreten
mit dem auto zur impfstelle zu kommen
ist gefährlicher als die impfung selber
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bet schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren